hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Skyrim okay going in the
river with traitor because we got the
golden claw of Moon basa and we're going
in there and we're gonna give it to him
and we're gonna get out that's it
show those thieves not to steal huh you
do out it yeah there it is
alright it seems smaller than I remember
yeah I don't care
funny thing you mean Myra wall I'm gonna
put this back where it belongs I'll
never forget this you've done a great
thing for me and my sister and your
sister yeah all your sister so fine
thank you sir
does she owe me a favor now bit of that
no okay never mind then fine alright um
cuz I don't need I'm gonna disenchant
that later
bla bla bla don't need to long Mose
goodbye Steel Warhammer Oh blah blah
blah blah blah blah mmm I need that for
enchanting something but not two of them
potions blah scrolls blah food blind
greetings blah aha here we go deep go
and earning good yeah ah firewood get
rid of those okay that's that then you
have any any steel stuff no but the
blacksmith would okay alright then yeah
all right there hey baby it's a fine day
with you around isn't it yeah hello
Camilla who's in this light you ain't so
pretty so nice I'm different about you
don't be a stranger
yeah okay alright see look at me kind of
weird-looking now the right light you're
pretty but I'm gonna go now alright
someone said that I need to level up
more so alright fine
a level level
with deep burgundy okay oh I got two
levels that was putting all in health
bah I got more levels I didn't okay now
I understand why you guys were yelling
at me because this is kind of a that's
kind of my bad I probably should have
done that a lot sooner
okay anyway get more damage here what do
I want well do I want to specialize in
great sword or great axe
what I think I'm actually gonna over to
heavy armor so anymore defense most
definitely
Oh fits whoa
what uh-oh
that's from the mod I totally forgot
that I had that mod even installed hello
buddy you lookin for a new blade
what Selby's in crap use your oh I can
use this because I've got crap to smell
don't I there we go yes great all of
them ah why can't I just press one
button I do all all right that was fast
I melt them down with my fists come on
iron or steel is what you need yeah he'd
that fancy elven stuff to the elves yeah
screw those elves who cares about them
bunch of douches anyway I could flare we
a Warhammer that would crush it oh yes
actually ah how about you Smith me an
iron dagger jurors everything you need
them I can do it you trust me well dip
boink boink
yeah except I was way better okay here
you go
dr. meanie not bad but it's a little
dull how about you sharpen it up don't
insult my will work metal and the
grindstone over there why ever a lot
ever douche hate you crapped it there we
go now I'll give you this stupid dagger
back to you hi there you go
this looks good you put time into your
blades they'll serve your well when you
need to ah ha ha ha craft into leather I
don't even know if I've killed any oh no
yeah I got some wolf pelts yes and wait
what man
that's a pain in the butt yes yes
whatever still leather
let's have you like a height helmet hi
there's the rest of what you need
okey-dokey wait where do I make a hide
helmet you're looking for a new place oh
it I I make a hide helmet in the Forge I
don't know
there you go here is your hide helmet
al4 I should hire you should prove the
fit you're not even gonna this leather
need to work but you're not gonna pay me
though there we go
it's a fine-looking a helmet Miss Kitty
I could you have why don't you keep that
dagger and Hulk doggy you'll remember me
when you're making yeah no I won't I
only come here when I need to sell you
craft lates helmets pretty much anything
to suit your needs there you go there's
that fine helmet if you liked it so much
whatever just a little bitter aha yes
yes with that crap
how much do these costs too much but uh
I'll foger for the money
no chest armor where's the chest armor
what what what I why I never I never
believe this crap all right fine
I'll pick up the chest armor later gah
so you clothes off my back
all right now I know someone said get
sky you i but actually don't mind this I
don't mind this I miss you I oh yeah all
right
oh no these two horns covered up my
other horns no oh now I don't have like
10 bajillion horns either way I need the
defense okay so I need to get to
Riverrun
or no I was in Riverrun I need to get to
wherever the hell the other place is I
know this game
get away birds don't like you anyway big
lizard coming through mushrooms
always stop by to pick the flowers Oh
God
oh my god oh lordy Lu oh goodness
gracious
okay that is getting worse and worse I
couldn't find a solution to the problem
I'll look harder next time but I don't
know I haven't heard of anyone else
having the problem murder da bunny get
me buddy yeah your dad murder yes all
right dear come here dear come here
don't you run away from me judge rat and
rat yes right I'll come on one more hit
one more hit come on come here come here
that's right into the water
you ain't gonna get away from me I'm a
natural swimmer oh come on yeah I can't
attack in the water can I back you're
not going anywhere
that's our just try to get on land Hey
what that you can't be that fast I'm an
Argonian
what what what what what douche dick uh
you said up you peach it all gonna cut
you off at the pass can't escape your
fate hmm dear yeah where'd you go
where'd you go dear what where'd it go
pretty go did you jump off
what happened to it where to go where to
go you win this round dear
I'll get you I will get you I'll get you
one of these days fine
oh yeah that's why I need to go I'm so
pretty in the distance okay fine the
deer got away from me
whatever don't matter product I could
swim in all this heavy armor but
whatever gah it stupid deer I didn't
want to eat you anyway you look too fat
not enough lean muscle yes right ugly to
pry L stringy
what who are you whoa whoa are going in
what are you doing what you doing there
what are you doing the right hand over
your valuables we're all got you like a
fish you gotta all seriously seriously
seriously walk away nice try that you
don't scare me huh I'm gonna ask again
oh you son of a [ __ ] your office that's
your last request ah ah that's what you
get I don't care if you are another
Argonian that's what you get for being
sneaky that's how I deal with sneaky
argonians
they don't get past me no one gets past
me no one
alright took care of that too many are
going into the world anyway so there can
only be one alright taking a shortcut we
ah we huh okay I'm okay all right what
do we got here a castle of some sort
Oh lag going on there frame rate dropped
up bit and now it's picking it back up
oh hello what's going on here fighting a
giant let me know it on the action gimme
gimme ah yeah get dead no oh yeah bring
it douche
didn't hurt Oh killing blow I got it you
all saw it
you all saw it I got the killing blow
strong and
okay all right guy creepy-looking
hey how you doing good and you'll have
stories you could make for a decent
shield okay you're talking to me now an
outsider well hello baby ever heard of
the Companions and order of warriors we
are brothers and sisters in honor and we
show up to solve problems that the coin
is good enough okay not for me to say
you left the talk to card lack whitening
up intravascular okay
the old man's got a good sense with
people he can look in your eyes and tell
your worth sounds good to me you go to
him I don't need luck baby but thanks
for your concern you're here to help I'm
here to steal potatoes are you gonna do
about it
oh yeah blood on the wind I know a
euphemism when I hear it anyway care
that no don't mind me while I steal your
crops just taking everything you own
nothing nothing just ignore everything
I'm doing is a nip in the air good for
my crops
yeah I'm probably not that good for
crops either I own the Pelagia farm just
outside the city walls new Meriel takes
good care of things for me I've oh can I
sell you back the cabbage I just took
pay for honest work honest paper on oh
you're paying me to pick your cross all
right
whoosh I'm so fast oh look at you do
she's got my way oh that was you baby oh
I'm sorry
whoa whoa whoa what uh hey buddy are you
okay alright buddy yeah yeah you okay
you're right whoa what done
but uh
and your eyes bigger oh yeah baby little
bit heavy on the mascara but that's okay
you so fine out with it
oh yeah my mother was a companion and
her mother uh-huh and all the women in
my family back to herati blackleg oh wow
I stayed with my father quite a story
until I was old enough for my trial
uh-huh
we hunted everything there was to hunt
ah the training MA didn't live long
enough to see me join uh-huh but I fight
to honor her and all my shield sisters
awesome that's awesome I'm so interested
in everything you have to say all right
I don't have much time to do with side
quests and stuff like that I don't know
if that for the main quest but I'm
really gonna try to focus on getting
through but a story
look settle then maybe work on other
stuff all right
anyway going up this Emily I'm gonna
write yeah okay Fred got my way all you
do shoes you don't know you don't know
me got my way lady wait you fine know
you're old yeah here hello see these
clothes with the dragons about yeah
that's me fish a business Olli okay
let's see um
oh yeah new line would be keeping an eye
on yeah whatever I survived the dragon
attack you all probably want to know
about that sorry it took me a second
remember what the hell I was fighting
for like that song
anyway that's all the time I got for
this episode thanks thank you guys so
much for watching the in theory cut off
I'll try to do my outro here my own hoot
what's going on here swallow that
stubborn pride of yours and ask your
Linda what's going on to help huh I'd
sooner bend my knee to Oprah's I don't
care who stopped writing check this hot
creamy you're following me
no no are anyways that's all the time I
got for this episode thank you guys so
much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next part
bye bye